KATE BISHOP
Some people have actually called me
the world's greatest archer.
[Bells ringing]
KATE BISHOP
Whoa! Oh, my God.
CLINT BARTON
Are you one of those people?
HAILEE STEINFELD
Finding the banter between
Clint and Kate...
CLINT BARTON
Where are you?
KATE BISHOP
Oh, relax. I'm taking the elevator.
HAILEE STEINFELD
...came pretty naturally.
KATE BISHOP
I'm surprisingly capable.
CLINT BARTON
Yeah.
BERT
Their chemistry was so on.
[Laughing]
KATE BISHOP
We're communicating.
We're listening.
CLINT BARTON
What?
[Laughing]
BERTIE
They can bicker and have you
giggling behind the monitors.
But then you see them
in action sequences
and it's just lightning.
JEREMY RENNER
The intersection of those two characters
becomes, really, the big base
of what this show is about.
I begrudgingly have her as a partner, if
you will. And then our friendship grows.
We certainly get our
butt kicked all over this show.
RHYS THOMAS
I enjoyed the humor and the tone
in the twists and
turns that it takes.
HAILEE STEINFELD
Collaborating with Jeremy,
it requires a lot more strength
than I think it looks like it might.
JEREMY RENNER
A lot.
CLINT BARTON
Definitely not this one.
KATE BISHOP
You don't have to say "definitely"
like that.
HAILEE STEINFELD
It's been such a wild ride.
You have no idea. This is literally just
the bare bones of what this is gonna be.
CLINT BISHOP
Bang!
KATE BISHOP
Holy sh--!
Your problem is branding.
CLINT BARTON
No, my problem is you.
[Laughing]